انا لو انا لو اني مسؤول في الاعلام لي
مسؤوليه فقرتين انا الغيها التحليل الفني
والتحليل التحكيمي لاني ما هو معقول اني
اجيب لي واحد ما عمره العب الكوره وينتقد
نيمار ولا كريستيانو ما
تجي سعود بن عبد العزيز بن محمد الصرامي
مسما اعلامي رياض تزامن التحاقي بالاعلام
الرياضي بمولد
كريستيانو 39
كريستيانو اسطوره وسعود الرامي عملاق
وجهان لعمله
[ضحك]
واحده هو الجمهور والسوشيال ميديا وليس
الاعلامي اصبح الاعلامي صد لهؤلاء والدليل
انك تشوف الان معظم البرامج الرياضيه معظم
محاورها مما يطرح في السوشيال ميديا وهذا
شيء غير جيد غير جيد لانك مهو معقول انك
انت تصير صاحب فكر تصير يعني رهينه المشجع
ما يصير يعني انت الان انا مقدمك كصاحب
فكر كمعد وكم هذيع
وكضت تنويريه المشكله اللي بعد زاد في هذا
الموضوع وهو الاخطر البحث عن المشاهدات
ممكن انا اسويلك زوبعه كاذبه ثم اجي في
الاخير القاها ما هي صحيحه بس اهم شي اني
انا وجدت مشاهدات ورده فعل ولا يهمني
بعدين ش الاثر السلبي على اللي سويته يجي
يورجن كلوب يقول انا صلاح لن يغادر
يونايتد لن يغادر ليفربول اتفاجا با
اعلامي قاعد في سمي يقول لا صلاح لعبنا
شلون لعبك يعني الاعلامي شايل مخه معطيه
المشجع
سهل جدا المفروض ان المفروض ان الناس
المسؤولين عن موضوعه تنظيم الاعلام
الرياضي يصير في شروط شروط الشهاده
شروط يشتغل سنتين
تجربه انه يكون قادر على صياغه الخبر قادر
على التحدث باسلب اعلامي واجد لكن اللي
نشوف لا كل واحد طال عمرك خاصه ي
شو اسمه جرائد الكترونيه يقول انا رئيس
تحرير الصحيفه الكترونيه ما ادري وين
الصحيفه لكن زي ما قلتلك انا الان المشكله
المشكله كبيره المشكله ان المعلن مرتبط
بالمتابعه والمشاهده عندك متابعه عندك
مشاهده
يجيك معلن ما عندك لا ذي ولا ذي انت تصير
عندك مشكله كبيره
كاعلام اساسا كل الرياضيين السعوديين نزه
مو بصحيح ذا الكلام والله مو هو بصحيح
والله شوف انا اقولها لك انا في هذا العمر
المتقدم انه مو هو بصحيح كل الاداريين
اللي يعملون في الانديه كلهم نزه ولا هم
صحيح بس الناس هذه العباره ذ مرتزق ورشو
يبغونها ورقه ضغط عشان تغير ارائك يعني
فهد بن نافل هل سبق ان اعطى شيء ابدا ولا
مسلي على المعمر
ولا اللي يسمونه هذا نمار الحايلي ولا
خالد العيسى محترمين بس الناس اي واحد
يقول رايه على طول يسوي هذه ما فيها والله
انا احلف عن نفسي انا واحلف عن الجميع ان
والله العظيم لا يوجد شيء اسمه رشاوي ولا
يوجد شيء اسمه فساد وانما هناك متعصبين
عندما يخسر فريقه يردد مثل هذه العبارات
وانا انصحهم ان لا ترددوا هذه العبارات
حتى لا تاثموا
بس الا انا بس سعود الصرام تقولوا شو
السبب يخافون من الجمهور كلهم يخافون من
الجمهور اصبح اليوم انت حتى لو انت كاعلام
تبي تقدم نفسك على انك رجل محايد مش ح
يقبلك جمهور ناديك خلاص تخسر جمهور ناديك
لان الجمهور هذا يبغى يحدد شخصيتك ويبغى
يحدد مبادئك ويبغى يحدد لغتك ويبغى يحدد
معتقداتك انا بالنسبه لي هذه ما تصلح لي
ابد ولا اؤمن فيها ولا اقدر انفذ اي واحد
ارى انه انه يستحق الانتقاد
بنتقد اي واحد يستحق الاشهاده بنشيد
[موسيقى]
فيه يحبون المناقر المناقر ضي ه تش
بالمشاهدات في مشاهدات لي انا شخصيا وصلت
الى 30 ماهو ب 30 ش 30 وصلت الى ملايين
وانا اساسا ماني مقتنع منها اللي خلي اني
اقولها لان البرامج الطويله ممتده اللي
تصير ساعتين وثلاث ساعات مش صحيح انك انت
تصير جالس لي قاعد لي جامد لازم يصير فيها
نوع من المداعبه تلقى هذه
المداعبه فجاه ماخذه صدا كبير انا لو انا
لوي مسؤول في الاعلام لي مسؤوليه فقرتين
انا الغيها التحليل الفني والتحليل
التحكيمي لاني ما هو معقول اني اجيب لي
واحد ما عمره العب الكوره وينتقد نيمار
ولا كريستيانو ما تجيي المحللين اللي انت
تشوفهم ترى ما عندهم الا ثلاث عبارات
الضغط على حامل الكره القائم الاول ها
القائم الاول ذ خلاص ها والحاجه الثالثه
اللي بتشوفها دايم 3 3 ا مادري 4 3 3 هذ
هذه عاد قسمتهم بضاعه بسيطه بضاعه بسيطه
بس انها
تكسب والله ش اس شفت
ترى ترى الاعلام موهو بباب رزق الاعلام
انا اقوللك مابز والدليل ان معظم الصحفيين
او الاعلاميين صغارا وكبارا لم يفرطوا في
وظائفهم لا الحكوميه او في القطاع الخاص
يعني انا كنت اشتغل في الجزيره متوسط
الراتب اعتقد 2500 شوف يا طويل العمر تبي
تعرف الوسط الرياضي من اللي ياخذ فلوس هم
فئتين فقط لا غير اللاعيبه والسماسره هم
اللي ياخذون غير كذا لا تصدق على مسؤوليه
واحد متغلغل في الوسط
الرياضي تلقى لاعب ما عمره رم اوت وموقع
عقد ب 6 مليون لا عمره لعب كوره ولا عمره
لبس فنيله ولا عمره سافر مع فريق ودائما
في القائمه السلبيه وتقول كم عقدك يقوللك
4 مليون في
السنه التعصب ورث من الاعلام الرياضي ونقل
لمدرجات انت لو تبي تقدم
نفسك كشخص محايد مش يقبلك جمهور ناديك في
يوم من الايام الهلال قدمني للمحاكم
الرياضيه وقدم علي شكوى وجلسوا
يعني يطاردوني في المحاكم الرياضيه لمده
ثلاث سنين وفي الاخير انتهى بالاعتذار
هذا ما يجعلني انه لما يتفوق نادي الهلال
اني ما انتقده اليوم انا اشوف ان النصر
متميز الان نمدح نفس الشيء الاتحاد نفس
الشيء الاهلي فالجماهير الرياضيه ما تبغى
الا تحدد لغه
[موسيقى]
الاعلامي مو بهم كل ما شافوني قال المتحدث
الصامت كل اثنين كل النصراويه والهلاليه
قلنا حنا خلاص متحدث بس انا اللي جايب
الملعب انا بالنسبه لي ثلاث صفقات انا
كسبت فيها الهلال وبفخر صفقه الملعب صفقه
كريستيانو صفقه تاليسكا المكالمات
النصراويين كانت تقول انه الملعب ذا اذا
انتصرنا فيه وكسبنا هذه عن عشر بطولات انا
اقوللك في كل الاحوال الهلال افضل من
النصر لو خذناها لعبه لعبه افضل من النصر
بس انت الحين قاعد فيده مطول
انت عطنا صفقه بس على اساس ان نربط الصوت
والصوره صفقه اي صفقه كذا في الكاميرا مع
الصوت كذا اي
بس العافيه والله